[Music]
we were told that we needed to build the
Ranger helmet from anthem I'm not gonna
lie we were buzzing this is the kind of
Commission that we have been waiting a
long time for we're doing this for the
best part of eight years now and I know
how to make a helmet but what we really
wanted to do was to bring the helmet to
life and the old kick-ass version was
smoked there was lights there was
movement there was everything that you
could possibly imagine from a badass
prop
the process we decide on create a master
created using the 3d printers create
Amol take castings and then those
castings are finished up painted whether
details I'll tell it to finish thing
my role in this project was to take the
3d files that you'll see from EA modify
them a little bit and make sure that
they're ready for 3d printing the files
are incredible it's the full resolution
high poly files from the game which is
great because it's going to be a
perfectly accurate representation of the
helmet these are some of the best
modelers in the world but the problem is
this helmet isn't designed to be a
real-world object the person that made
it obviously is an engineer they don't
know how this would realistically work
[Music]
this is awesome I mean the first prop I
ever made was the predator pistol from
the Mass Effect series so I am super
excited and so glad I actually finally
get to work on something made by Bioware
my jobs been to build mechanisms and the
smoke machine I make everything work and
everything move the 3d files there are
empty 2d shells and we need to build
them into actual volumes and that's
mostly what Quentin was doing if I
worked really closely with him to make
sure that these things could actually
fit together in the real world
the main problem was the faceplate was
clipping through the rest of the helmet
so we had to start cutting away at parts
of the faceplate to make sure you had a
clearance and could rotate in two places
to get right up and round but luckily
David is you knows what you just kind of
quite in me the right direction and just
like holes here
surberg was here jump on so it's working
there's a little wobbly
it doesn't quite go down the straight
[Music]
as a 3d artist normally I'm working
slowly on a computer and the products
that I make are entirely digital but
with s I'm working right next to two 3d
printer is an absurd as I'm finishing a
piece I'm sending it to Tom and it's
getting printed out right next to me
using these different types of 3d
printers meant that we could create an
identical 3d representation of this game
asset when the 3d prints come out they
look great from the distance but you've
got bill lines they need to disappear
before you can get a mirror finish
sanding is probably ninety-nine point
seven two percent of what we do we need
to join it all together we need to join
the gaps that require something we need
to paint it before you paint anything it
needs to be silent any imperfection
needs to be sanded i we do a lot of
sanding you enjoy saying I love
something something is the best no I
don't do something anymore I pay people
to sand did a lot of sanding here
because Tom doesn't think somebody's got
to do the sand and getting a job like
this am as pretty much like a dream come
true for me because I'm a huge Bioware
fan I'm pretty much captain buzzkill I'm
the one has to get everyone to actually
do what they're supposed to be doing
they die running a boat shouldn't each
other with space guns and talking about
virus the worst part is doing this job
is that haven't been able to actually
play the game because I've been too busy
doing this
[Applause]
the temptation to just use the 3d print
is always there but 3d printing they're
not as strong and it's durable and you
want to get one chance if you've spent
all that time preparing a 3d print and
you're going axed it and drop it
that's it ruined with a more we can
create multiples
[Music]
all that looks like a cream egg in fair
would you die fear tend to think yeah no
discussion that's nice
I'm actually quite nervous this is the
first major point that we can yeah the
silicon molding was painting on layers
and layers of silicon to catch as much
detail as possible and then building a
rigid or jacket to keep that in place
but it's the best one so far
the face place was a little bit more
difficult because we needed to capture
detail on all sides so we needed to
create a two-part mole for that we use
an epoxy to skin the outside and then
backfill that with film so that we could
keep it nice and lightweight to make
sure it can move with the mechanism we
didn't decide to just make a helmet on
our kind of inspiration was what would
you do if you were the mechanic working
on the javelins helmet where would you
put it you wouldn't just leave it lying
on the ground you need somewhere to
mount it we can do your testing Deere
mechanisms when we first approached the
idea of creating limb platforms we were
quite concerned with the time constraint
and Glen completely ignored everything
he said he actually sent us the fill
suit and it's covered in details and I
just start to take pieces from I was
like that looks cool
that was cool and that it started
stacking it on the base my initial
response was it's beautiful
ahead of are we gonna build a control
man you're off the case yeah kind of
went a bit over that but just shifted a
lot of my work into someone else's
problem that's kind of my job yeah I'm
the start of it I'll make the 3d files
and it's like you guys deal with that
I'm out here later we decided that it
was too good of an opportunity to waste
and that's where myself and David got
crazy we added in smoke machines we had
it in LEDs we used a genuine rusted
metal that was cut in our plasma car we
went absolutely wild with it Tom's
original vision of it was going to be
smoke and light so I had to come up with
a way to produce smoke on demand without
buying off-the-shelf smoke machine which
tend to be very expensive and very big
the solution is taking an off-the-shelf
eight taking it apart putting some fans
and some ducting to push the air through
the vape the end result is three jets
with smoke two coming out the pipes on
the stand and one burn straight up into
the helmet so you get a nice smoky for
coming out from the helmet it just so
happened that Tom already had a bottle
of blueberry vape on him it was the only
one that didn't have nicotine in it so
every time we tried test the machine the
entire workshop filled up with a nice
blueberry smell in a smoky haze
[Music]
the first step of the painting and
finishing process was to add an
automotive primer from that we applied
on some base coats and then we set about
detailing with the airbrush once all
that was done we set about destroying it
effectively we used sandpaper and
sanding sponges to sand through the top
coats just like you would get on a
mechanical piece that was user in the
battlefields to add scratches to add
dents into it and then the last touch
was just to go in and add a little bit
of weathering we spend like a long time
making this handling it like so
carefully and trying not to get a single
scratch on it and then dust Park comes
around and we start like flinging stuff
at a scratching a getting a scalpel to
it it makes like such a huge difference
[Music]
[Music]
for me personally I'm for the whole
surrender studios our approach is always
that sort of I for detail we want to
make sure that things are as accurate as
humanly possible our blood sweat and
tears went into it and we've really hope
that the world enjoys
[Music]